good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday it's
home day here at the morning toast so
make sure to hump someone you love today
i sure have already
looking at theo hey sweetie pie he's
looking so
sexy yeah really so provocative honestly
like
he's just dan like the way he has that
sway in his walk he's like come here mom
hey get it if you're watching on youtube
today
hi how are you apologies for yesterday
yesterday's episode was
so [ __ ] but i think we fixed the
glitching problem for once and for all
yeah we have this glitch that appears
every now and then and we believe we
fixed it i don't want to jinx it but of
course let us know
we tried something completely new today
so hopefully that is the cure
and that won't happen again but if you
were wondering what happened to
yesterday's episode
the second half of the episode is
available via podcast if you missed it
honestly it was really good we recapped
a bachelor and like we were just talking
about great stuff
yeah and it was just like great energy
always great energy honestly we have
a lot to talk about today we do some
really interesting stories
the tv recap segment has real housewives
of dallas which was honestly
such a good episode of television like
there was just there was everything like
it had
all the appetizers entrees and desserts
yeah it was so good i ruined it for
myself because i kept pausing like i
probably it probably took me three hours
to watch it because i was pausing
to get on the phone with margo to
convince her to cut her hair which is um
which was a worthy cause
i agree so i still loved it i think this
season is shaping up to be really good
like a great group of women i'm really
excited to talk about it
and i'm i'm happy to have them back on
my screen yeah no my plate is full
though my plate is full but not on
tuesdays but not on tuesdays no it was
nice
the only other thing we have to talk
about is it's wednesday dear toasters
our advice segment
we have some great submissions today and
we have an update from the girl who
farted on thanksgiving and where that
led her in her life so stay tuned for
that at the end of the show and what was
our advice ron for the hills
i don't remember what we said i think it
was run
if i know myself yeah yeah
the tracks the tryptophan man oh we look
at you
it'll get ya i finished high school
musical the musical the series yesterday
and i just have to say it was so superb
like five stars all around
i literally like cried a little bit at
the end like it was just a beautiful
ending and i loved all the characters
and i'm gonna miss miss darbus
so much and
she's a queen and i've been listening to
the soundtrack and that song that she
wrote
don't you think this is the only thing
that i remembered from the show like it
was [ __ ] that they didn't
show us her ballad during the musical
hundred percent and she started singing
it during the musical so i'm like yes
we're getting a miss dartmouth
dharma spotlight and then ricky's like
crying outside and we have to skip
the only thing that i thought was funny
um and i felt like the show kind of
avoided these like classic
disney channel tropes where like there's
literally like no
way any of this stuff could happen like
i thought it was pretty realistic for
the most part
except that the play was terrible like
there were so many mishaps like
literally ricky came and then ej like it
was just so messy ricky kept like
switching in the middle yeah but then
like the dean of the conservatory of the
actors of denver
thought she was great and wanted to op
spoiler alert
offer her a position like that's really
not how those things work especially
with the play that i saw was really
subpar
yeah and just like the first thing you
do when you're casting a play is
cast it and so by the when it's play
time like have your casts ready i know i
agree and like ricky thinking he's like
doing something for nene by not like it
was so lame and so disney
but i looked past it because there was
so much more that the show had to offer
like so much heart
like if i went to music one of the
attendees in the audience of that play
and like you know the students so you
know what role they got and then like
someone comes out like
and they're acting different i would
just be like i wouldn't be like oh now
he's playing troy
yeah what the [ __ ] is going on no also
like there was just so much
there was only so much i could believe
you know like so ricky is in the first
act playing troy bolton and he's killing
it
and he sees his mom and dad are having
such a good time then he gets in his
harness to do his little dancy thing in
the air
and he sees his mom brought her new
boyfriend now i just have to say like
that like the mom would never do that
like
she was like a smart woman like she
knows this is an important night for her
son like she never would have
surprised her son on his big night with
her new boyfriend while he's flying
through the air
literally while he found out that his
parents were getting separated like
two weeks ago like that would just never
happen so there were some things that
like i took umbrage with and had like a
hard time suspending disbelief
but i tried to let like look at the
positives miss jen was such a positive
um the iconic gay love story in the
drama department was a huge
high um i really liked
obviously miss star the young mistarbus
and that song that she wrote on the
piano which was stellar
and a lot of the other music of course
the one that went viral on tick tock is
so good but that song that ricky
wrote for her as like the opening night
present was so good like there was a lot
of really good songs the song that i
like is out of the old
the one that i like is wonderful
because i thought it sounded like like
that um
like one republic song oh that's good
yeah i just thought all the songs were
like
they didn't have they had they didn't
owe us that like they didn't have to
slap
so [ __ ] hard on the album but the
music is like iconic
yeah it's really good i'm glad that you
watched it and it just
gives context to everything that's been
going on this week with olivia rodriguez
yeah
queen olivia queen olivia we stem
we do um other than that i don't think
there's much to discuss just a little
smoothie update i'm on day seven i'm
feeling really good today i sat down to
do my makeup and i really could see a
difference in my skin i was like
this is the first time in a while where
i'm like looking at my face and i'm like
what's that what's that
oh i need to drink more water because
i'm like so beyond hydrated because
you like pretending to care well what
should i do
you know i'm damned if i do and give me
a close-up
i'm going like this okay so you don't
want me to nod no you don't want me to
nod
are you [ __ ] serious i was literally
trying because i watched a show
yesterday you could see that you're
trying that it's so hard
it is like i'm just i don't think i did
anything wrong you had no business
calling me out
no no yesterday you had business calling
me out like i was being snarky today
like i'm literally just listening to you
you're not like waiting for it to be
over
by the way that's just me you're not
interested in in how it's going
listen listen that's what i do like when
other people talk no matter what it's
about like i'm always just waiting for
my turn to talk again
i don't know it's just a lot of people
have been asking about my cleanse
and so it's going really well i won't
nod i'm really excited like to
hit the finish line but it it every day
is better and easier
i'm making hard-boiled eggs and they're
delicious you're trembling but it's a
journey
trip what is that have you ever seen
that tick-tock no oh my god this girl is
so
funny she does like really like
interesting comedy and she's like
you know the feeling like when you have
work to do but you're just sleeping
instead
she's like you're trembling but but it's
an adventure like it's so funny and i've
been using that in everyday life and
that's the
the the smoothie journey oh well i
haven't
become familiar with that reference yet
but yes that is the smoothie journey so
all's well on the smoothie front yeah
i'm just i feel like i'm really starting
to
see the see the benefits that's great
i'm so excited thank you claudia
you the whites of your eyes actually do
look quite bright dude how does my skin
look
like the same your skin like you don't
have problem skin also because once i
put on makeup like you don't see the
things that i see but when i wake up in
the morning i'm like hey
yeah wednesdays are always hard for me
because during the week i wash my hair
sundays and wednesdays
and so like by wednesday it's like
crusty and like literally like i can't
even run my fingers through it i'm sure
it looks good but
it is so crispy right now like you could
literally make a grilled cheese on my
hair
it looks really good it doesn't feel
good oh well it looks good that's what
it
counts but i know the feeling when it's
like i honestly just cannot wait for the
day to be over so i could take a shower
and like
i don't really even like showering that
much i took a lovely bath yesterday
so peaceful oh nice i haven't taken a
bath in a few days i think
maybe that's on deck for today i love
baths becoming a part of your journey in
2021
i know so stellar i think you tracked in
some duty on
no it's like grease from your boots yeah
i guess so i haven't worn these in a
while
oh you know i see look on the bottom of
your foot there's some duty like not
duty like schmutz
greece it's looking for greece are you
working in an auto shop that i don't
know about
i just you know i have all these secret
projects smoothies grease
it is what it is okay ready to get into
the stories because we have a lot to
talk about let's do it
without further ado it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and to avoid any rdh complications it is
my duty to let you know
that today's episode is brought to you
duty
is brought to you by our patreon channel
patreon.com
morning toast what is patreon you ask it
is our subscription service so this show
five days a week on youtube and all the
podcast apps is totally free
but we have a subscription service where
you can pay 7.99 a month for five
extra episodes from jackie and i their
vlogs their youtubes their
uh podcast episodes they're sometimes
radio episodes that can be quite
controversial
so yes five extra episodes for 7.99 and
it is a great way to get more content
and then support your local podcast
so head over to patreon.com your morning
toast once you become a member you get
access to our exclusive
facebook group the toast after dark
which is our last remaining facebook
group
and it's really a wonderful corner of
the internet very peaceful over there
yes
lovely head over there check it out home
tour coming soon
yes okay first story big story a lot of
people are talking about it and i'm very
curious to get your thoughts
army hammer oh you know what i was
literally meant to text you last night
saying we must talk about army however
we must talk about army hammer army
hammer is a person that i truly
just don't care about like whether he's
doing something positive or negative
like i just don't care about him
hear ye hear ye i totally agree
like literally who like he who you know
but like people feel really strongly
about him because he's very handsome
yeah and they love um call me by your
name and they loved his marriage to
elizabeth chambers i think her name was
they were like really cute like dallas
queens yes and so he's in the news now
and you know what like
the level that this story is at of like
craziness
defies my indifference for army hammer
of course
you know what i mean no now we have to
talk about it no it's like no now i'm
intrigued like it's like hilaria baldwin
like i don't
if she did something positive or
negative before i wouldn't have cared
much but like what she did
yeah defied my level of indifference
well speaking of hilaria baldwin like i
am just
sure she has sent army hammer flowers
thanking him
for taking her name for washing her out
of the news cycle
yeah okay armie hammer wanted to quote
cut off a girlfriend's toe and keep it
in his pocket
and make her his quote property until
she died according to leaked instagram
messages that talk about
rape and cannibalism army hammer said he
wanted to cut off his girlfriend's toe
and keep it in his pocket according to
new disturbing screenshots
leaked by a woman who says the actor
sent her vile instagram messages
about rape and cannibalism he began
trending on twitter sunday night after a
series of screenshots
showing graphic messages he'd allegedly
pen to a woman were leaked by the
nominee anonymous now private instagram
account
house of effie the actor is yet to speak
publicly on the matter and multiple
requests for comment have so far gone
unanswered
the alleged messages said to be sent
between october 2016 and february 2020
include conversations about bdsm in
addition to numerous sexual references
to cannibalistic acts and blood sucking
that so he was
such a freak like saying he wanted to
chop
someone up and like eat them in pieces
like i can't
no like he said if i wanted to cut off
one of your toes and keep it with me in
my pocket so i always had a
piece of you in my possession he also
later says that like he
is a cannibal and that he's never told
anyone right he writes like i think i'm
a cannibal i've never really said that
to anyone before he wrote quote you just
live to obey and be my slave
i will own you that's my soul my brain
my body
my spirit that reminded me of taylor
swift my brave mother
oh my god i mean honestly like this
story is crazy but it's also like
not funny like because they always say
like when terrible things happen like
where were the signs you know like this
is a sign like army hammer's
crazy like he needs to be put away for
life like
he's insane yeah and then also
the instagram account shared screenshots
of um
other things that army had sent like his
hand on a script with the same tattoo
that we know that he has
and a selfie so really verifying as much
as you can that these messages are
authentic
and i had heard that a bunch of like
army hammer stands like who even knew
those people existed
um made a fake uh screenshot of this
girl's instagram story saying like sorry
i lied like these are all fake
and that really got a lot of traction so
i think a lot of people were doubting
the
validity of these screenshots but like
they're 100 true like i believe them to
be 100 true
yeah and so at the end of the day i
guess army hammers into cannibalism and
that's just something you should know
no i know and like honestly in his text
messages like you could really see like
how delusional he is because he's like
i think i'm a cannibal like wow i've
never told him but he's like the
innocent
he's the insecure cannibal
oh my god yeah like i was going to say
something more along the lines of it's
like
you know that's like not something like
you open up about
like he's like a bachelor you know
because someone's like one-on-one
like i think i might be bisexual like
that's the first time i've ever said
like that's a legitimate
thing to admit to yourself to admit to
people around you a cannibal like no
yeah no you go on the bachelor and you
have your one on one yeah
i think i'm a cannibal i've never said
this out loud matt but
i'm a cannonball cannibal or cannonball
cannibal cannonball it's confusing i
guess i now you've confused me
um also today's episode needs to be
named insecure cannibal just remember
that oh for sure for sure let's jot that
down
um anyway so that's just like what's new
with army hammer
he hasn't responded i don't know what he
will say
it is extremely alarming but and i'm
just like
so like glad that i have no part in his
fandom yeah like i don't feel really any
type of way except i feel bad for like
the person who had to receive these
messages because they're honestly
traumatizing
yeah and i just didn't see for 2021 like
the first cancellation being army hammer
no uh yeah that's the first one because
ellaria
was 20 slides into 20 20. we really need
to start keeping a list
no i think that's okay army hammer
number one honestly he's so weird and
justice for his wife
yeah she i read in the daily mail
article like spoke out and said she like
100 believes like everything
that and i thought that when they broke
up it was very weird
because for a while like to me who is
army hammer to you
social network yeah and
i don't even think of him as like a
relevant celebrity even though a lot of
people do but i never saw call me by
your name maybe that's why
so to me he's just like the guy who's
married to the girl with the bakery you
know
and there's just so much more to him now
yeah no people like absolutely love him
and he's a really acclaimed
serious actor like a-list not anymore no
no no not anymore
now he's c-list welcome to the club
anyways so that's that's what's new with
army hammer and um
now you know army okay next up some
big programming news that everyone's
talking about netflix is going to be
dropping
a movie a week in 2021 wow
yesterday netflix put out a teaser um
in national commercial spots uh showing
a lot of the
slate that is coming in 2021 it's
largely consisting of original
productions as well as some splashy
acquisitions
the slate has 71 titles across genres
from musicals to action romantic
comedies to family animation
dwayne john similis mccarthy halle berry
jason mamoa amy adams ryan reynolds
chris hemsworth and lin-manuel miranda
are among those featured in the sizzle
reel which was released
yesterday i watched the sizzle like it's
so exciting
hyped up i mean if they were going to do
a movie a year a movie a week i feel
like 2020 was here to do it but it's
fine better late than never
um it just netflix has a lot of action
movies and and the sizzle
had a lot of action movies and so i just
feel like at least half of these are not
yeah
my genre but there's one movie that's
starring leo
and jennifer lawrence oh it's a netflix
movie it's going to be on netflix
i don't know that i feel like they might
have acquired it because if they
them like under contract we wouldn't
hear about it
so i think that movie like that's a
really great pairing that sounds really
good
yeah that's so interesting of course you
also i saw this morning the trailer to
all the boys i loved before
three and i just love those movies
they're so lighthearted and i feel like
they're really always very very well
done
and the fact that noah centeno and um
lara jean never dated is like the best
thing to happen to the franchise because
they're such good friends and there's
like no toxic energy a la kissing booth
and i'm just excited for like a
feel-good movie and it comes out
literally in like three weeks
yeah and then i was just gonna ask you
your thoughts on kissing the three
coming out but oh it is
yeah oh it was part of the trailer too
but yeah i only saw to all the boys i
loved before because i my eyes are
automatically just drawn to premium
content and i do my eyes are naturally
diverted away from shitty movies
oh my god honestly the fact that they
have the the nerve
the gall the audacity to put out a
kissing booth three
after the absolute train wreck that was
kissing with two
they should know better and they should
scrap it like the the
the pure hatred that is
radiating between the two main
characters is so toxic and is so
not necessary for a movie that they
should really just scrap the whole thing
and just like let it die i don't even
think i watch kissing booth too
i never finish it and if i did i don't
remember it it was such a piece of [ __ ]
they hate each other like i feel like
they filmed two and three at the same
time so that energy
just isn't too easy i mean
the first movie was was good
but mostly you were like obsessed with
the fact that these two were dating in
real life
then i watched to all the boys i loved
before one and i know i've spoken about
this before but to all the boys i loved
before was like
so much better when i went back and
watched kissing booth again which i had
loved kissing with i'm like this is the
trash movie that i liked
it's like to all the boys i loved before
showed me like what true love is you
know
yeah and i couldn't go back and ever
since they broke up and they must have
had a really bad breakup because like
the the hate is so
tangible like on screen um i'm
definitely not gonna be watching kissing
booth three and i might even lead a
movement against it
okay sounds good uh i mean if people
like it if it brings some happiness like
let them be
no no okay are you ready for our next
story
what are the movies are coming out oh
and they say like
like names of movies that we know uh
there's a heist film called red notice
starring gal gadot
dwayne johnson and ryan reynolds western
called the harder they fall with regina
king idris elba
and idris elba and then lovecraft county
uh starring jonathan myers it's not like
amy adams is in the woman in the window
which i think is based off of the book
so i think i'm going to read the book
because that's just a fun thing to do i
would like um
is there like a young adult film coming
out like another franchise there's also
a movie called don't look up starring
jennifer lawrence
leonardo dicaprio ariana grande timothy
chalamet kid cudi and meryl streep
what so that sounds starry yeah
yeah and honestly sounds too starry
sometimes when there's too many famous
people in a movie it's like bound to be
bad
cats oh you know what they did break it
out by genre so are there any young
adult
like love rom-coms like more to all the
boys i love before or kissing booths
those are my favorite romance castle for
christmas
that sounds like a christmas vanessa
hodgins type of movie yeah fuimo's
conchionus okay kissing booth three love
heart
the last letter from your world love
heart i don't know does it mean
there's no description like they just
broke it out okay so they just broke it
out the last letter from your lover the
princess switch
three wow i guess those movies do well
okay to all the boys i love always and
forever
and an untitled alicia keys rom-com oh
wow
okay but there's no like young adult
section no but musical
section oh a week away i've heard about
it tick tick
boom never heard of it is that a tick
tock musical and then there's movies for
the whole family
a boy called christmas a winter's tale
from sean the sheep
back to the outback finding ohana loud
noise
night books robin robins skater i think
these are probably on animated
yeah ninja turtles tmnt
troll hunters that's us
um wish dragon in yesterday okay very
exciting year for
netflix i mean the streaming wars are so
real like
i i i can't even say with certainty
where i'm spending my most time these
days
honestly i'm spending most of my time on
hulu just because that's where lost is
but if not for that like i'm watching
originals all over the place like
netflix obviously had bergerton
but i've heard so many things about the
wilds on amazon i think i'm going to
start it this weekend people are like
obsessed with it
so the streaming wars look at us we're
just a bunch of consumers benefiting
from the streaming awards we really are
since i love bridges so much i think i'm
gonna watch downton abbey at some point
because i think i would love it and
i don't know why i haven't watched it
yet it's like
fantastic remember we were having the
conversation about the ton
yeah downtown it's not downtown abbey
it's downton
oh my god that's the ton yeah i'll find
out yeah
let me know that's a really good call so
anyways that's exciting
a movie a week next story is really
crazy
robert wilson says she was once
kidnapped at gunpoint in africa
what she said the petrifying night
occurred in rural mozambique and left
her and her group fearing for their
lives
she was on sky one series straight
talking she said we were on this cattle
truck and these men came on another
truck with a lot of guns
they pulled up beside us with the big
guns and they were like yeah you've got
to get off your truck
she didn't specify when the incident
occurred she said her group obeyed
orders and were taken to a house in the
middle of nowhere
despite her fear wilson said she was
able to remain calm she said i felt like
i was very good in the crisis i was like
the team leader
they sat us down and i said everybody
link arms because i was petrified that
they may want to take one of the girls
or something
she said that the kidnappers released
the group in the morning and then they
made a getaway to the south african
border they were never given an
explanation for why they were taken but
wilson believed it had to do with
smuggling
oh my god that's [ __ ] crazy you know
what i was just gonna say i mean i guess
that could really happen to anyone but i
feel like celebrities
of course there's so many perks of being
celebrities but i feel like a lot of
celebrities go through like traumatic
things because they're so high profile
and so wealthy like
harry styles was robbed at gunpoint kim
obviously like there's so many like
things you can point to it's so scary
it's so scary and it's crazy that this
happened and we had no idea that's
truly traumatizing but i don't think
this happened because she was famous
because i don't i don't think these men
knew who she was
yeah no but still just very very scary
and a very
crazy headline to read yeah very crazy
headline to read today yeah
i also read another headline that just
had me in my thoughts and i think it's
going to take us on a really fun journey
okay
jon hamm and harry hamlin both
auditioned for the oc
for the role of sandy cohen oh my god i
mean neither one of them could have done
it
never but jon hamm was on a podcast he's
given the news to a podcast called too
long didn't watch
and he said that he auditioned alongside
harry hamlin and peter gallagher
who were around 15 to 20 years older
than him right he said i remember
walking in and being like is that peter
gallagher why am i here i love peter
gallagher
but i was just like dang yeah he
obviously we know that peter gallagher
landed the role ham said he was often
called in to audition for roles
alongside older actors because he never
looked young enough to be in high school
he was about 32 years old at the time
when he read for the part he said i
missed out on all the dawson's creek in
the early early wb shows so then they
were like come in and play one of the
dads but i don't look like
a dad old enough to be that either yeah
that's true
i could never see harry hamelin i mean
peter gallagher isn't jewish but
sandy cohen was like the quintessential
like old jewish man and he really got
that
character like nailed down perfectly
like i couldn't see harry hamlin
ever playing like a jewish dad obsessed
with bagels do you know what i mean
yeah i you know what i feel like
obviously we can't see it any
differently because that's how it was
and i guess
harry hamlin like could have but they
made the total right choice
100 i mean sandy cohen i mean honestly i
can't keep saying sandy cohen without
saying sandy canyon with the eyewitness
news movie minute
but sandy cohen was literally like a
an integral part in the success of the
oc like undoubtedly a hundred percent
like his
energy that he radiated and i don't
think that harry hamlin
no radiates what did sandy cohen do for
a living in the film
i mean seriously a public defender and
then eventually he goes into the private
sector eventually like he works for
caleb and
you know he's a lawyer so but they were
living in the oc off of julie's money
off of kirsten that's what i meant
naturally no they weren't living off
their neighbor's money
no kiki yeah got it i haven't watched
that show in so long
it's so good it's so good i a few years
ago
rewatched the whole thing and it was a
prize
up until marissa dying that's the thing
don't bother yourself with the last
season
but you just like literally spoiled
everything everyone knows yeah but like
if someone didn't watch it like you just
spoiled okay if someone if you don't
know
like even vaguely you know ever what
happened that's the conversation we had
at the beginning of the week
then you're not interested in ever going
to watch the oc
yeah and like we literally had this
conversation at the beginning of the
week like if show premiered over 10
years ago like there's no such thing as
spoiling it yeah and also i don't think
that that's necessarily a spoiler
because it's not like the whole time
you're like it's not like an
action series that's like she or isn't
she right you know
it's like she just left the show yeah i
mean she was loki towards like the end
of her time they're like the worst
character like with her just
putting everyone in danger and her bad
decision making um
but the show is not the same after the
best is like the first two seasons when
like
summer and marissa and ryan and seth are
like this for some and like they hang
out at summer's house and summers are
convertible and summer's house is so
nice and her dad is never home like
that's the best part of this year yes
yeah you should re-watch it if you're
looking for something
yeah i also just like need to buy that
house that summer lives in i just
remember like being obsessed with it
like the white columns and the big
stairs
yes sickening sickening so that's what
could have been
that's crazy yeah caleb john hamm did a
podcast
i know and i also can't believe that
like peter i guess i don't know who the
big stars were at the time but i feel
like now like
harry hamlin and jon hamm are really big
stars compared to peter gallagher 100
got that part yeah but i think at the
time peter gallard
gallagher was as famous as jon hamm and
harry hamlin are now
yes just funny how fame works you guys
yeah fickle and fleeting
our fifth and final story is a little
jeopardy news because there's a new
guest host on the scene do you know who
it is
ken jennings katie couric no no like a
new name of someone who's going to host
it
oh no who an exciting name aaron rodgers
will host a guest host in episode of
jeopardy he says he's excited
an episode okay uh the green bay packers
appeared on the pat mcafee show and
shared that he always looked up to the
longtime host alex trebek
he said one of my idols growing up was
alex trebek they're doing some guest
hosting spots and it's going to be
released pretty soon
but i have the opportunity to do one of
those i'm excited about that opportunity
with jeopardy
that's cool i mean i don't think he's
being like groomed to be the next alex
or anything but that's like a fun
promotional thing yeah and i think
they're gonna do like a lot of like fun
celeb guest hosts
and i wouldn't expect that from aaron
rodgers and hopefully he lets us know
like what's going on with his family
yeah like hopefully he just like a
sidebar like does he talk to jojo
right that family drama was like so
crazy
um yeah and that is like i think people
who air their family drama like in the
public sphere no matter like what the
case is like i think those people are
disgusting but i don't think they
they've aired their family trauma like
they just don't speak and
no there was like tweets and comments
like
because we still don't know why they're
beefing so they didn't air it
jordan said no not on the bachelor i'm
saying like afterwards on social media
like jordan like
like tweeted aaron like when he was
doing charity during the holidays he was
like you could do charity like not even
call your mom
remember it's just like it's gross like
handle it privately like some things
even as like
someone who loves gossip and celebrity
like to see families fighting in the
public sphere like it makes me like
sad for sure and also it's crazy that
they're both celebrities like
and they don't speak to each other well
they're not like even
nearly on the same level yes they are in
the celebrity sphere
and the celebrity sports sphere like
they're definitely i feel like they both
could end up at the espys like obviously
jordan and georgio would be sitting in
like the 13th row
while aaron rodgers would be like in the
first or like he might even be hosting
it
but still they could end up at the same
events for sure yeah
so i think that'll be pretty cool you
have that to look forward to yeah and
i feel like you get a glimpse of
people's personalities when they do
stuff like that
yeah and he also participated in
celebrity jeopardy in the past so he's
just like a big jeopardy fan i just love
aaron rodgers i think he's like so cute
um and i love seeing celebrities doing
things out of the ordinary things that
they do like out of their element
um like tina fey said it's like seeing a
dog walk on its side legs totally
so yeah especially athletes too i feel
like celebrities are always trying to
like
do as many things as possible host
comedy like a million things for sure
but athletes have like very one one
track minds because they're working all
the time
so to see them in a different space is
fun yeah so
exciting um let's dive into tv recap
because the real housewives of dallas
episode was on last night and it was
so good because first of all i think
that
it is now the second most wealthy
franchise
after beverly hills okay just above like
tiffany really brought up the group
average in terms of style money home
cars wine cellar closet fingerprint you
know like i
fingerprint i loved that i did agree
with stephanie that like inviting people
into your home and like literally going
through your personal items like look i
got this gucci bag like
that's really tacky but i'm sure the
producers like asked her to do that and
as a consumer like i was not upset but
as a friend i would be like this is
weird
yeah cameron museum watch what happens
live and cameron and tiffany are like
seriously beefing
hardcore on twitter like in real life i
guess in the show it hasn't gotten there
yet but she was saying that she was like
i love seeing ladies closets in general
so like i liked it but
like when you have people in your home
like i guess it's tacky to like take
them on a grand tour but
i feel like it was asked of that of her
yeah i mean i did think it was weird i
wanted them to show i wanted her to show
her house around but then i saw her
in her master bathroom which is like a
really private place and her like shoes
were off and i'm like
this is a really intimate tour like yeah
and also i feel like maybe they could
have done that tour like with just the
cameras bravo tv
and because if i were stephanie or
d'andra i would have been like oh yay
like
like you know it's weird and stephanie i
don't know
when you know travis is stephanie's very
new money but i think a lot of the way
that she acts about money is very old
money so like
i think she like and then i thought it
was just so interesting how like when
they're getting ready for the um
dim sum party you see stephanie's closet
and it's
literally so sickening sickening i was
saying the same thing but it's like we
still don't see the whole thing we just
are getting glimpses and it's sickening
yeah um so as it pertains to tiffany
like
and cameron not getting along like i
kind of see that they would butt heads
and i think that tiffany i don't really
feel like i know her yet but i did think
it was like so glaringly obvious that
like
she was like almost going to start stuff
with carrie bringing him but the women
were like that's just how she is like it
says something to you with you
but she was like claiming she was being
bullied into drinking tequila
when like it came to the food like she
was bullying casualties she did exactly
what carrie was doing
right and i feel like i think that the
women in general like we're being a
little disrespectful like about the food
like
like like two year olds especially when
it's like someone's culture like it's
food is deep is like very connected to
people's culture and like especially in
front of the people in the restaurant
like i thought they were being rude
yeah but i i fell for cameron because
like when they were describing how
cameron eats i'm like
that's me like i have the palette of a
four-year-old like i eat chicken fingers
french fries and rice for every meal so
like if that i was in that situation
like i wouldn't know how to handle it
and i thought that cameron was being
very gracious and just like being like
i'm good like don't worry i'm not saying
i'm not eating it but just like
and playing around with it yeah and like
trying not to be obviously disrespectful
but tiffany was just like really
studying her yeah
and i thought that was unfair and like
she was definitely um
doing exactly what she was mad at carrie
bringing him for doing for sure and i
think it pissed cameron off because like
cameron tried to go about it in like a
very
de-escalated sort of way and and then
now cameron just was saying on
watching live she finds tiffany to be
very bossy and
i'm sure like in that instance that sort
of might have been like the first thing
that sets them off
like not being friends because they seem
so similar to me
no they even i feel like if i close my
eyes they sound the same too like the
pitch of their voice yeah
and i would think that they would get
along but
we'll see something um has happened to
the westcott
to cameron westcott this season because
she first of all is like so clearly the
star of the show like her confessionals
are just iconic and like
her home life is like so interesting
even though like who cares about like
selling and
you know what i mean like it's not
particularly interesting stuff but
they're just such an interesting family
and like
i don't know something like happened to
her she like blossomed over the last
season
she's so funny like when you said that
thing about the centerpiece like
i cackled i cackled i literally texted
it to you i didn't know where she was
going because she was just like talking
about the party she's like by the way
when you have a party
girl get a centerpiece yes and they
zoom in on the table i really was like
empty it was hysterical i agree that
she's really becoming like sort of a
narrator of the show and i
am enjoying it there were a few moments
and i wish i could remember them where i
like
truly cackled i actually love love love
deandra
and i think that scene when she was
sitting with jeremy and first of all
when they were talking about their um
love languages and how hers is acts of
service which is mine too and like
when he was like cleaning the vent like
she was so happy like that was so
relatable
and i just think they have such a good
marriage like he's such a nice guy
and he's so handsome and i just like
love when like they're in their house
and i just think they have like a really
good like foundation and i think that
they're like like really perfectly
paired
yeah um i i would like to know more i
usually find people's um
reconnecting with my family so boring
but i want to know more like
the money like how much and that's not
the same money that
deandra's mom has right that's her
stepdads
i don't know i think it's the same i
don't i think it's the same
simmons money i don't think so i think
because they're saying
she said that
was her mom's name dee dee's husband
wasn't her father but like basically
raised her and she was in the will
but then she had another will from her
biological father
who like had another family but they
were kind of close
um and she wasn't like i think that
there were two like huge wills i think
deandra was like rolling in the dough
interesting i didn't get that but it's
very
unclear yeah um what else happened in
the episode oh the episode opened with a
conversation
um with brandy with brandy and tiffany
which i thought was like
so great yeah like for both of them like
i'm sure that tiffany felt like this
responsibility like coming on as the
first asian housewife of dallas
um amid this scandal like she she felt
the responsibility to like
address it um but also not like start a
fight over it and i thought she just
handled it like really maturely
and i think that brandy probably really
appreciated that conversation
i agree i think it was a good way to
move
forward between the two of them brandi i
mean i wish she could have been at the
party but like with all this covid
filming like it's really i just caught
up on oc and it's like
unbearable so she has to quarantine and
she can't go but i look forward to her
like i feel
like she's so upset with herself
broken like shame yeah and it's it's a
very sad feeling
yeah and so i just i i'm excited for her
to get back in the mix
yeah um the other thing is i forgot
because so much happened
like last season with leanne firing but
like i forgot how
annoying carrie brittingham is um and
her fighting with deandra reminded me of
like
oh she just like loves to poke and prod
and deandre really said it perfectly
and then i was remembering like all the
stuff she did last season before like a
huge blow up so like nobody really ever
addressed it
but she is like an annoying friend like
that like just always [ __ ] like
looking for to like make a
you the butt of a joke yeah i don't
really remember
her from last season i thought that i
liked her but i agree like her energy i
was just not feeling it that's not
someone i could ever be friends with
like
who's just like always poking at me
exactly and it just reminded me i
totally forgot
about that side of her it seems like all
the girls are really close with her but
it also feels like she
is kind of like getting a back seat this
season like in the first episode she
didn't have any
solo solo moments but then we see her
family
in the second episode which i think that
that her daughter i think her name is
olivia
saw herself on tv last season and
literally like it changed her life like
seeing how she spoke to her mom which
was so disrespectful like
i remember growing up like kids who
spoke to their moms that way like it was
just
so crazy rude like and i think she
was probably mortified because her
behavior is much and i actually think
she made a really good point about like
going to college and expanding your
horizons and then
coming home and like feeling like the
people that you grew up with like are
just on different levels than you like
emotionally and intellectually yeah um
but she's an entirely different person
new hair new hair attitude
i literally didn't even know it was her
and i agree her behavior last season was
disgraceful atrocious
yeah um so it's actually turning out to
be like a really good season i just love
the women of dallas so much they're so
funny
in their confessionals like they don't
hold back i know that their like ratings
aren't great
and that makes me really sad and i
really want like everyone to get on
board i just don't know how any
franchises ratings could possibly be
worse than
oc like if you're if you're able to
watch oc you should be able to watch
everything else
i know but oc just like has this
built-in following because it's been on
for so long and dallas just doesn't have
that
oc's on season 13 dallas is on like
season five yeah
and i just don't want it to get canceled
like it's really really good and i feel
like it's like
on the brink like that's just a feeling
that i have yeah i think this is going
to be a really great season i think
tiffany is an amazing addition me too
to the cast i just if you are looking to
start housewives like start dallas it's
really really good um
and they just like need to be saved i'm
like so worried about them yeah
um okay let's dive into your toasters
our advice segment where you can write
into deertoasters
gmail.com about anything that's going on
in your life anonymously
and we will read it out and do our best
to give you some advice first up hi
claudia and jackie
hi okay i can't even believe i'm saying
this i feel crazy
i've been with my fiance for seven years
we were on on again off again in the
beginning but we worked everything out
moved past our mistakes and he's a p
john however we both suffer from
horrible anxiety
i'm always anxious that he's cheating on
me i literally ask him up front like
once a month because i'm that crazy
for background he has never cheated on
me before and has never cheated in any
relationship in fact he has been cheated
on
i have such vivid dr i had such a vivid
dream that he was cheating so vivid that
in my dream i told myself to check his
phone
i did and i found nothing i still have
such a pit about it though
what has been making me suspicious is
the face that we are getting married and
is the fact that we are getting married
in june but he hasn't been wanting to do
anything in the bedroom
he keeps blaming his anxiety the lack of
physical needs
is fueling my cheating theory he stays
up way later than me even when he's
tired he's super weird when i touch his
phone or his watch
i truly don't know if i'm overthinking
it am i being a crazy person or is this
really a woman's intuition
sincerely a crazy stan that needs help
well this sounds exhausting okay i think
there's two things here first of all
the fact that you are so worried that he
is cheating on you and even though he
has never done anything to give you any
inkling that he is
i think that maybe you should like talk
to someone or see someone to sort of
unpack like why you have those feelings
right because i think at the end of the
day it's like
you can trace that back to like an
insecurity either in yourself
in your relationship and that's just not
how you want to live
right i think you need to work that out
and i think um
therapy would actually be a great place
to do that and sort of trace back like
why
you are so sort of paranoid
um and then the second part about now
his behavior has changed and he doesn't
go to sleep with you and he's super
anxious too
maybe you go to couple's couch i was
gonna suggest that as well this just
sounds
um like you guys just need to like work
some things out but it sounds like you
otherwise a healthy marriage like
yeah and and sometimes relationship
relationship yeah
sometimes i feel like maybe the
relationship is like and i
think that a lot of girls do this like
the relationship is so fine but like
you look for problems yeah and you like
sort of sabotage it and a lot of times
it's something that starts within you
and your relationship could be
absolutely perfect but you would still
treat it that way and so i just think
that's something
that you should talk to someone right
because nothing in here makes me think
he's cheating like staying up late is
not a crime
and you went through his phone you've
gone through his things and like there's
no there's nothing to make you think
that
there's nothing so i just think this is
a lot like in your head mental and yeah
sometimes you just gotta go unpack your
head
yeah no it's the suitcase gets really
heavy and sometimes you just gotta unzip
i know but also like i feel like matt
james now when i say unpack like it's
his favorite word
is it yeah he's always like he said it
like that's this thing this season like
claire wanted people to show up
matt wants to like unpack people oh i
did not yeah pick up on that but it is a
good
saying so i agree i don't want it to be
over saturated and then it's like loses
its flavor 100
all right next up dear claudia and
jackie it's every girl's favorite kind
of drama
wedding drama first off i want to say
that you two set the bar high for
toaster weddings oh you were both
beautiful and stunning and your venues
were everything of the sort that's so
nice thank you so much
here's my issue my friend and her
husband got married last summer coveted
style
20 people went sadly her bachelorette
party was canceled because we didn't
feel comfortable traveling at the time
it was scheduled
so fast forward to this spring she's
wanting us to do her bachelorette even
though she's already married
here is my problem i just flat out don't
want to go
once she's married already two i'm not
ready to travel to the state we're going
to
three i have a serious quarantine body
that i'm rocking and i don't feel like
being around a bunch of skinny [ __ ]
and thong bikinis
please help do i convince her we should
not do it do i tap out or do i just go
sincerely a toaster who dreams of being
a bride one day so she can show her
friends how to be a nice one
that's so funny that's tough honestly
this girl i mean this is an easy one you
just say
like you won't go because of covid yeah
whatever you need to say blame it on
kovid like
it is just like covent has been so
treacherous but it has given us people
who love to cancel plans
it has given us ultimate increase
hundred
percent and so whatever you need like
maybe if if you sang to her
i don't feel comfortable traveling to
this state even though i think that that
would completely suffice like i think
i have friends and people have said that
and we all
are like fine with it and vice versa or
if you need to like plan something a
week after
her thing where you're like oh i can't
be i have to take part
i would have to quarantine but i have
this a week later and i need to be there
for that i think that
this should be so easy for you to get
out of like use copenhagen as an excuse
like
while you still can yeah i think tapping
out of plans that you don't feel
comfortable in for whatever
reason they are is like the most healthy
thing you can do in your adult life is
like
just say no to things like you don't
have to be everywhere and like
fomo can be so toxic but so can keeping
up with it like going places you don't
want to go
so i think you're fine like you don't
have to go i like i can't tell if this
girl is being annoying by having a
bachelorette party after her wedding or
like i should feel bad for her because
she had like a 20 person covered wedding
and like she's just trying to make the
best of it
um i'm kind of annoyed with her you know
it's like the moment's over like you had
the covered wedding you didn't wait like
yeah but i think if she framed it as
like
maybe in not in the spring but even a
year on her wedding anniversary it's
like let's do a girls trip not a
bachelorette party like let's just go on
a trip
right to celebrate like [ __ ] we don't
need to all get the sashes and play the
games right
but like i wanted to get into the trip
that we didn't get to take like that
sounds really fun to me yeah that's what
don't do it at a time when it's like
your friend
other people are getting married and
having these conflicts like i would do
it post-covered completely like i agree
wait i agree um all right now i'm really
excited to do an update from the girl
who farted at her thanksgiving dinner
with her boyfriend's family and it was
really loud
dear jackie and claudia here we go the
time has come an update from my
thanksgiving after all if you will
an update on the thanksgiving fart heard
around the world quick recap i farted
during the moment of silence at my
boyfriend's thanksgiving dinner or
should i say
ex-boyfriend now claudia and jackie
please find peace in knowing the actual
fart
sorry please find peace in knowing that
the actual fart itself played little to
no role in our breakup and was actually
never spoken about
however the absolute terrorism that
despicable moment caused on my brain
started to take its toll i found myself
constantly squeezing my cheeks in fear i
couldn't go on
i came up with a reason that was
technically true it's not you it's me
i would like to take this moment to
thank you after submitting my story your
concern with my bowels hit deep
sorry i forgot i'm not remembering what
we said the more you talked about
the more you talked about how concerning
it was that i farted before dinner
the more i began to realize this could
be a legitimate medical issue
so i did in fact had to go go to the
doctor to find out that not only did i
have
asymptomatic coven
but that i had irritable bowel syndrome
as well
you cannot make this [ __ ] up your
concern
and diagnosis saved my toilet and my
family
thank you for doing god's work i am
forever grateful for the doctors
and the toast oh my god
that's crazy well the fact that she had
ibs is not shocking
no but the fact that she was coveted
positive and she didn't even know when
she only went to the doctor because of
us
and she could have infected her
grandmother like we are literally
saving lives saving lives wow that's
that's what you can get when you take
our advice
i'm shook i'm shocked that's the
craziest update i've got
sounds like she's doing well too and so
even though she cause she's funny like
yeah she's
a comedy writer like the way that she
writes is very funny yeah
i'm well thank you for for updating us
if we've ever written it uh
if you've ever written in and we've
spoken your uh request on air please
write us in on an update
i love hearing back from it and i'm so
happy that you're doing okay taking care
of your body
yes love to hear it would love an update
i so didn't see that coming so like
happy for you
and these answers hilarious um that's
our show anything else you want to talk
about oh i mean i am writing a book i
don't know if i've mentioned that
girl with no job.com slash book oh and
you want to do something cool
so if you've gotten my book um or if you
haven't gotten my book and you're trying
to get a copy
goodreads is doing a giveaway they 100
that's so cool and now i'm like on the
page with all like the real authors like
on goodreads giveaways and like we're
just like you know giving away books
so they're giving away 100 books and 100
people can win
i put the link on my um story but i
think if you also just google like
goodreads girlfriend job giveaway
um you can get it and i'm really excited
and
that's all i have to say so exciting we
shall
see you tomorrow thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast
monday morning show we deliver the five
stories that you need to know
month through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we could use some more
subscribers come on
and if you're listening as a podcast
you can find us anywhere podcasts are
fine and you can find us anywhere
podcasts wait what do i say
our found spotify itunes stitcher public
video i already cast box all the places
whoever you listen to podcast five nice
morning totally five star view about
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing hump
day don't forget to help someone you
love we're back tomorrow bye